in this video we're going to look at
another familiar pattern of resistors
called parallel resistors
and i've shown here two resistors that
are in parallel
this resistor is in parallel with this
resistor and the reason is it shares
nodes
these two resistors share the same nodes
and that means they have the same
voltage and they're called parallel
resistors so if you share a node
share the same node
then you share the same voltage
and you are in parallel
that's what that word means
now if we go look closer here
we'll see some interesting
things it's hooked up we have a battery
here some voltage v
and because there's a path a complete
path around here we're going to have a
current we're going to have a current i
flowing in this circuit
let's label these resistors let's call
this one r1
and this one r2
those are our parallel resistors
when the current reaches this point here
when a current reaches this node it's
going to split it's going to split into
two different currents that current
and that current we'll call that one i
one because it goes through r1 and we'll
call this one i2
and that goes through r2
now we know any current that goes into a
resistor comes out the other side
otherwise it would collect inside the
resistor and we know that doesn't happen
this one comes here and they rejoin when
they get to this node and flow back to
the battery so the current down here is
again i
the same one is up here
now what i want to do
is i want to replace these two resistors
with an equivalent resistor one that
does the same thing and and by the same
thing we mean
causes the same current
to flow
in
the main branch
and so that's what's drawn over here
here's a resistor here
we're gonna we'll call this v again and
we'll call this r parallel
rp
and this resistor
causes the same current i
to flow here
and now we're going to work out an
expression for that
we want to figure out how to how do we
calculate rp
in terms of the two parallel resistors
here
okay so let's go at it
what we know let's see what we know
about this over here what we know is the
voltages on the two resistors are the
same we know there's two different
currents
assuming that these are two different
valued resistors
and now with just that information we
can apply ohm's law and we use our
favorite thing ohm's law
which says that voltage on a resistor
equals
the current in the resistor times its
resistance
so let's write down ohm's law for r1 and
r2
okay
we know the voltage we'll just call the
voltage v
this is for r1
v equals
i1
times
r1
and for r2
we can write a similar equation which is
v same v
equals i2
r2
now there's one more fact that we know
and that is
that i1 and i2 add up to i
and these are the three facts that we
know about this circuit
what i'm going to do now is come up with
an expression for i1 and i2 based on
these expressions plug them into this
equation
okay i can rewrite
this equation as i 1 equals
v over r1
i can write this one
as i2
equals v over r2
and now i'm going to plug these two guys
into here
let's do that i
equals
i1 which is v
over r1
plus
v
over
r2
let me move the screen up a little bit
okay now we're going to continue here i
just want to rewrite this a little bit
i
equals
v
times
1 over r1
plus
1 over
r
2.
okay so here we have an expression
it actually sort of looks like ohm's law
it has an i term a v term
and this
r term here
let me go back up here here's our
original ohm's law i'm going to write
this i'm going to solve for i in terms
of v just to make it look look a little
more obvious i can say i
equals
v over r
and what i hope you see here is the
similarity between this equation and
this one down here
so i have this r here
and what's happening is this term is
playing the role
of that
resistance
so i'm going to bring this equation down
here
and write it right down here
times 1 over r
i'm going to call this rp
because what i want is
for this expression and this expression
i'm going to set those equal same i
same v
these guys are equal i can write it all
i'll just write it over here 1 over
r p
equals 1 over r1
plus 1 over
r2
this says we have a resistor we're going
to call it rp or r parallel
that acts like the parallel combination
of r1 and r2
so this
is the expression for a parallel
resistor
if you want to calculate a replacement
for r1 and r2 in parallel
you do this
you do this computation
and you get rp
so let's do one of these for real
here's an example
here's an example where i've actually
filled in some numbers for us so i have
a 20 ohm resistor in parallel with a 60
ohm resistor driven by a 3 volt battery
and what i want to do is i want to
combine these two parallel resistors
and find out
what is the current
right here
find out what is the current that's my
unknown thing here i know everything
else about this
so let's use our equation we said that
one over rp
was equal to
one over r1
plus 1 over r2
and let's just fill in the numbers 1
over rp
equals 1 over 20
plus 1 over
60.
that equals
let's just make 60 the common
denominator so i have to multiply this 1
by 3
3 over 60
plus
1 over 60
and that equals 4 over 60.
and so now i'm going to take the
reciprocal here
rp
equals
60 over 4
or
rp equals
ohms
so what this is telling us
is if we have two resistors
in parallel 20 ohms and 60 ohms that is
for the purposes of calculating
the current here that's the same as 15
ohms
it's hooked to three volts
just like that
let's check what the current is the
current is
i
equals
v over r
equals 3 volts
over
15 ohms
that's equal to 0.2 amps
or you can say it's the same as 200
milliamps
so we actually have now simplified our
circuit from two resistors to one
resistor and we were able to
compute the current here
which is
0.2 amps
and i would invite you to check this by
going back
and computing this current up here to
make sure it's the same and the way you
would do that is you would calculate the
voltage the voltage here is 3 volts
3 volts across 20 3 volts across 60
you'll get i1 and i2
and if you add those together
you'll get the total i and it should
come out the same as this and i think
that's a good exercise for you to do
to prove that the
expression for a parallel resistor
1 over
our parallel can be computed from 1 over
r1
plus
1 over
r2